jojo was geht hier soll marx und
herzlich willkommen zur nächsten folge
minecraft nero mit petn pentrit ist wie
immer nicht dabei es hat wie immer
irgendwie ist es wieder ein shader drin
angst vor meinem pc ich hab ihn extra
deinstalliert den den shader spot dass
ich hier kein problem ab und es ist tag
leute amen amen
ich habe gar keine sachen hast du
irgendwie was brauchbares bei dir in
deiner wohnung ist es mega passt du
essen
will man im weltall glaube ich ich
musste wieder zum schiff vor und da habe
ich keinen guten empfang ob die
framerate 25 frames gerade so 23 16
alter wäre nicht mit 720 ps
mache ich also mein pc ist ja echt an
seinen grenzen
und ja heute ist auf jeden fall die
folge wo ich mich mal wieder aufraffen
muss aufrütteln muss ihr müsst wissen
gestern kam keine folge weil ich privat
gebraucht war da kann ich jetzt nicht
mehr dazu sagen so was was kann ich mir
bei den clown die eisen rüsten brauch
ich ja nix also szenario ist eigentlich
alles nehmen dann hast du keine tipps
wie kann ich von diesem billig allee -
hier liefert das alles hat er mein
jahres werden glaube ich nicht
ich wollte halt noch dominik wippen guck
mal so wer ist da noch genug zeug das
ich ja da ist auf jeden fall noch genug
da
da gibt's noch zwei zafira soll die
wollte stimme geben
ok dann gebt ihr glaube ich habe ja
schon einmal meine meine chance vertan
quasi und hab einmal die ausrüstung von
der verlorene übels tank war
wir werden auf jeden fall irgendwie das
schaffen können dass sie das ich dir
bald irgendwie was zurück ihre weise für
mich langsam ein bisschen schlecht
countryfest der der retter unserer
ganzen starten sie das gefühl vor allen
dingen bei komme weil da geht es ja
immer noch recht opulenz tagein tagaus
wieder neuer torreicher vorbehaltenen
dimension zu gehen
das alter ist gibt's doch nicht ich will
zu dem schema und hier sind wirklich auf
dem weg zum schluss dass einziges
sichere essen gibt sind 20 oder sony
sind niemals in so birk und ist es
natürlich wieder opengl gecrasht kann
trotzdem nicht so leute wir gehen wieder
auf den server als letzter ich hoffe mal
das ist jetzt nicht mehr so zulegt und
der shader ist jetzt mal wieder drin
verdammt ich hatte den manu heraus
gemacht gehabt beim letzten
ja ohne spaß vielleicht schrecklich
aussehen auch meine ganzen presets weg
da sitze ich hätte das ja alles
optimiert dass ich dies oder das ist so
ja genau ich muss mich da eigentlich
durch kämpfen aber ich regeneriere nicht
mehr wissen ich sterbe ich hab zwei
erstatten
nee du hast glaube ich gar nichts und
ist dass sich da was haben dass das
weizen wächst auch nicht warum wächst
aber hast du kleiner baum tiere bei lilo
so ein paar bohnen mir geschichten
gefunden und das alter voll viel
irgendwie aber das hat gar nichts
gebracht alles du hast ja auch kein baum
glaube ich nicht mehr hast du nicht was
ist denn die ganz einfach ein paar
millionen
ja ist einfach so pilz keine ahnung ich
es mich jetzt einmal voll und dann
täglich einfach die ganzen monster
regeneriere ich nicht nur kurzem bislang
genau es lang gerade so dass ich mich da
einmal durchkämpfen und dann baue ich
die nächsten melonen die ich mit der
hohle aber an dass es hierfür probleme
sind oder schreibt mir also ich bin
voller erfolge gleich das in der stadt
bot mit level 70 anteil herumgelaufen
ist irgendwie so gar nicht das darf gar
nicht sein
gott wird also keine ahnung
wir müssen müssen wir die stadt
verlassen ja hab ich auch glaube dass
gefühle unserer stadt spreche schlimm
geworden
man stirbt also wirklich der wahl was
hier abgeht das ist so sieht auch noch
so mops die auf long range angreifer im
alter
wenn ich von diesem ganzen fächer nicht
irgendwas vernünftige job bekomme und
ich habe die alle aggro gepusht ich muss
erstmal ein bisschen of distance gehen
vor fünf herzen schon wieder nur noch
okay bisschen regen leute das wird
erstmal die das projekt stadtreinigung
passt auch so granit ran
dazu wollte übrigens noch ein paar worte
verdienst gab wirklich leute die das
schlimm fanden dass ich mich gerade die
trump genannt hat natürlich mache ich
spaß über den vollidioten der jetzt mal
ohne witz glaubt ihr ich unterstütze das
tram er ist selbst habe das wetter alles
aufgefasst verstehe ich so gar nicht wie
man das so aufsteiger steht schon fast
genau so hat ein schade mir sieben
fehlern gedopt wir sind hier noch ein
paar übrig ein paar monster night falls
und world nämlich schon wieder mein haus
rein
ich muss doch essen wohl noch der arme
ding jetzt habe ich alles hier
freigekämpft kirche jetzt hier runter
und ich fixlohn ist was für monster gibt
eines lohnes was für monster geht eines
lohnes käse noch jede menge berechne ich
mir okay ich es mich jetzt einmal voll
und ich glaube mit eisen rüstung dürfte
es zumindest mal zum haus ist sich also
ich würde mich wundern
dann warte ich das wieder tag wird bzw
in der nächsten folge baue ich mal wie
es auch in einer anderen stadt schon
deshalb einfach mal am ganzen ufer
entlang per mail oder macht das ohne
reiz also wir sind essens technik nicht
so krass ist es eine schande dass wir so
ein problem mit essen haben alter weil
jeder ist irgendwie darauf erpicht oder
mit seinem seinen eigenen erfolgs
darauf hat man einfach keinen bock weil
man weder produkt ist einmal will ja
sachen schaffen wir das aber auch
entdecken und leute eine sache geht es
auch noch zu sagen finde ich es gab ja
einerlei einige kritik sag ich mal an
der oso an sich man kann auf jeden fall
sagen
das sind besser im schiff unten im bauch
vom schiff unten ist einfach anders
vertreten
da ist es nicht so stark oder aber das
sind diese riesen und die die geben an
florence haben nur 50 leben oder
ja ich habe angst
die m50 leben ich habe angst und ich
werde einfach nur nach hause und es sind
einfach sind die glatt wieder gespannt
die ganzen fächer fürs lohnes noch drei
sekunden
jetzt bin ich einfach ins wasser
gefallen das ist stiften wir wieder
nicht da wie beim letzten mal
ich bin halt wirklich wieder genau an
derselben stelle aber ich glaube ich
schaffe es ich schaffe es diesmal
da ist sie dann besser meistern
diesmal also wenn ich dem geister
schaffe vielleicht macht er fiel damit
ist also groß
okay noch ein investor heißt es in sich
hatte habt ihr jetzt die stark in
erinnerung weil es halt auch nicht nicht
falsch für so die die hand experience
weil ich hab ich kaum ob ich getragen 15
sein
was passiert da kriegt man welche
bewahren aber in grenzen dagegen stärkte
monster tempo
du bist in dimension dessen monster
level 15 hunter so richtig gar nicht
töten aber es kräftig an du bist einfach
mehr los so gut
erst wenn ich irgendwie voll ohne aus
graz geht es sofort von dem motto pack
erstellen das ist sowieso trifft ja eh
nicht so oft man kann von ihnen
entkommen so ist es nicht nur er muss
also aufpassen quimper normal wenn du
ein rollenspiel spielst ganz normaler
gibt's außer gebiet da kannst einfach
nichts behandelt da ist einfach da nicht
denn so
so sexy fischer live muss ich mir mal
wieder vornehmen ich muss jetzt mal ein
ganzes blatt magic zeug zurückholen
stimmt dieser geschichten zurückgeworfen
muss mit ihr kann ja klar
total so 55 sand muss ich mir holen
das ist auf jeden fall recht also es ist
total doof gewesen so matt pack mäßig
hat man hat mich das echt hart
zurückgreifen das glaube ich
das habe ich ein bisschen essen aber das
wieder so ein usa hat muss also die
stark die haben die ich will wird schon
seines relativ gut hätten aber die 190
aber ich erwische ich mich ins becken
den fackeln ab aber nicht so stark sind
sie auch nicht sinnvoll routen und sturm
hoffe dass sarah wissen wir dass naja
bleibt erhalten mit jetzt an aufnahme
confixx geschrieben da sind große da
doch große pass auf die große liebe
schon dass wir da auf kosten and ancient
heißt dass ich okay
ja ich sagte ja groß was das für eine
nachricht musste einfach aus ich bin
nicht wie ein bisschen sand holen das
ist dass ich bisschen progress mag ich
werde mich die ganze stadt ist der kern
des nachts ja ja ich weiß
einerseits muss sie aufpassen dass ich
meine fortschritt nicht verliere aber
andererseits muss ja auch erstmal wieder
fortschritt maigler da stimmt aber da
ich okay jetzt bin ich wieder in meinem
haus gleich wie findest du eigentlich
mein kleines hässliches baumhaus karas
halt klein zum überleben
ja genau was anderes habe ich auch erst
mal damit vor so dann brauche ich
erstmal wieder platz zwei die ensembles
habe ich noch das dürfte eigentlich ein
problem wenn ich glaube wir kriegen
zumindest unser blatt magic zeigt was
wir bisher geholt haben wieder hin
dieser gattung meter ich glaube den
inhaltlichen gast gehört es geht auch
immer zurück also komme hat in seinem
backpackers verliert man ja nicht wenn
man stirbt hatte eine gas tränenfilm
jahr in mir bisher in bisher noch nicht
geschrieben so wie er mir das geben
könnte oder so ich hab gesagt dass ob es
mir vielleicht hier rein legt das wäre
keller herrscht ich wollte mir auch noch
anna mathes geben weil wir wollen dem
portal bauen.de schneller weil die alte
die planche gehen wollen
die nächste dimension dimension spor tag
ich war da los und haben schwarz wie
geht das noch mal man kann auch
irgendwie aus dem ja aus dem turnier
items mit hoher aussagekraft meine ich
dass ich hier so drückt und dafür erst
mal keine zeit
manchmal was unproduktiv beim craften so
wurst bus einfach so ganz einfache
sachen geht wie irgendwie sachen
möglichst schnell reinzulegen oder was
bin ich voll schlecht sondern packe voll
opfern so dann koche ich mal dass usa
fleisch dass ich ein bisschen vernünftig
das klingt irgendwie cool finde ich seh
ich koche das erstrittene trap das
gustav fleischer einheit und ein die er
brauche jetzt erst mal um die warte ich
glaub ich brauchte im ried bleibt ob ja
gar nicht mehr machen möchte kann dann
direkt den starken machen so glaube ich
kenne mich damit ihr nicht aus da
bräuchte auch meintv nations deshalb
habe ich auch alles verloren ging das
noch mal die nation slade oder brauche
ich noch mal mehr
susan für okay aber wir schaffen schon
wieder ein bisschen was leute und ich
bin relativ happy darüber stand wieder
so ok ich muss aber wieder abhauen jetzt
in einer an alte und ich bin im winter
hat nicht mal voll gerecht aber das
sollte ich das mach' jetzt wirklich also
ich gehe jetzt nicht los wenn ich nicht
mal ein klein bisschen safety im
nächsten das los angeles darstellt kommt
also knapp dem tod
ja ich kenne auch ne war auch nimmer
krise bei mir ach so ich habe hier emma
stone ohr und hole mir die ganze zeit
die sachen von hier
das ist ja bisher glaube ich sogar noch
besser als als jahre n bar dass der
sender stone aus dem netz das ist ein so
netter erstes von drei jahren
rüstung wobei rüst und weiß ich gar
nicht sie könne aber der wasserkante
glaub ich mache mir erwarten kann nur
nach genauer und das macht 14 tag damage
und jada auch okay na gut dann habe ich
zumindest noch einmal netz ein zweites
set ok und hier ist jetzt ein
ein skelett das werde ich gehen dann
können wir direkt bauen wieder raus
machen und meine eigene kleine farm hier
und ein bisschen vorantreiben soll das
ist auch ganz harmonisch hier
ich wollte eigentlich wegen dimension
broich viel essen wie ich das gemacht
habe ich heute jagen geht's halt bevor
gelangen dann
mahnung auch irgendwie millionen kennen
ist nicht das gelbe vom ei melonen ist
über stressig findet ja und ja wir
machen hier irgendwelche maps okay die
nacht vorbei es klappt kurs erhält gar
nicht mal so lang aber melonen sind halt
sind halt auch nur so angedacht glaube
ich so vom format projekt hersteller das
man halt keine ahnung im notfall es
genommen
ja ja ist so eigentlich soll nun aber
nicht als der haupt essen nahrungsquelle
sehen will kann sich diese natura vier
mal recken aber das bringt ihm gegenüber
droppen die irgendwas welche fischer die
natura dinger keiner was es ist das sind
diese diese kultur um piepsen und
wassermelonen
doch wer also grüne was ich gegessen
oder ist der bastler der mich letzte
folge getötet hat also der mir meinen
ersten punkt macht erst wassermassen nie
getraut
wie kann man essen es ist wie ganz
normale sache mit und peter ist dieser
schola der hundezone der mich in meiner
bude getötet hat davon sind auch
skelette leute wir machen fortschritte
auf jeden fall auch ich meine allein die
stadt jemals so ein bisschen zu säubern
von diesem ganzen flugzeug hier von dem
ganzen gewicht schon ziemlich falsch
habe ich jetzt gerade die stadt aus den
augen verloren darum ist ja mein bruder
so ok ein bisschen sand wollte ich noch
holen ist ins 18 minuten haben wir ich
glaub ich hab zwei minuten durch den
durch den arzt habe ich das buch jetzt
aber auch sicherheit kann man auch etwas
machen und welche rüstung
ich hasse dieses feature die eines
lohnes geben mancher hatte sogar ein
bogen 40 weil ich hatte echt viel ich
habe ja vor
dimension zu gehen und mir irgendwie so
ein
das macht das 27 effekte mit schmerzen
naja ich aber ich deshalb ein bisschen
mitleid verbunden und super sein lob
stadt im blick
ja 27 tag der menschensohn grossrat
thierry und wie meins nicht platt mit
glück zu tun also mach das nicht immer
die nähe zu kriegen ist ein bisschen
glück 4 prozent chance walter das wäre
heftig also damit wäre kompletter über
lord die great lakes als die großstädter
den vorteil dass ich ein bisschen von
range kanzler treffen weil diese nicht
mit ich sterbe haben wir sind ja auch
lang ein paar schon panisch weil doch
diesen sommer ja das ist glaube ich die
kleinen schwester sind besser ok na gut
ich muss jetzt hier am anfang mal
komplett ohne machen aber ich glaube
diese voll kriegen wir das den den ort
noch wobei die kriegen ja wahrscheinlich
eher nächste freuen wenn ich ganz
ehrlich bin ich glaube ich beende jetzt
auch demnächst mal auf jeden fall leute
wir sind wieder zurück wir haben uns
wieder einigermaßen aufgestellt und
schaut noch ein bisschen zeit fast 550
sex gemacht und wir 15
bis 11.15 nach müsstest du erst auf wenn
du hast ja noch zwei minuten - das ja
noch zeit
okay stimmt eigentlich aber ich glaube
das glaubt was du wissen musst du das
nicht ich weiß nicht wie lange es dauert
weil das problem ist wenn man das
abbricht dann verliert es seit dem
sommer so
wir sind als 5000 mp wieder rein strömen
müssen ich könnte mir schon vorstellen
dass es funktioniert aber ich gehe
lieber auf nummer sicher einmal das in
der nächsten folge nämlich jetzt direkt
mit ge ja ich weiß seit und dann war's
das von heute macht mut und bis zum
nächsten mal schießt du verfolgt muss
man vom server tschüss